bindi Irwin brings wildlife into the  ballroom do you want to give her a touch  to achieve really beautiful it was  switch up week on Dancing with the Stars  and 17 year old bindi Irwin used her  animal instincts to welcome her new  partner Val Chmerkovskiy do you need  help because I'm not gonna be the one  rescuing you she's beautiful where the  chances that on switch-up week is where  she brings out this giant Python man yes  it was very scary I trusted her man if  something would have happened it would  have been on your conscience baby  the duo slithered on the dance floor  with their ChaCha  Vale's brother max was the guest judge  for the evening and gave them a ten  their final score 37 out of 40